>>> THROUGHOUT SHOW, F
IDTO AENTH
HAILIN THE LATE NSVEFOD AG.E  WT
COMMUNICATOR, RONALD REAGAN WAE.
A O WALYE BI        A MODATENY
RU STUHAE ESTABLISHMENT.HEAT MOD
HE SET A
AM>> THOSE COMMENTS COMING AFTEN
N PRESIDEI US.
WECIATE IT SHEBEN A BIG LICAN PY
ER DREOULDMEOGE
THAT I
WHENK ATT'S
HAPPENING E REPU
S OR
CENSURED FG THE RUMPOULD YNKY AY
PP
HE WOULD BE ASHAMED OF HIS  PS O
LONGER HIS REPUBLICAY OF
OUE
CONCERNED, JIMHE SAID IT ITH,  .
COUNTRY, AND ONE OF EM HTI
TI
THIS JPOUTING, YOU
SAA NA
EMERGENCY, AND MY FATHER WOULD
HAVE SEEN ATCLEARLY, I'M
SUREAS U.Y DIFFT FROM T REAGAN
PARTY ABOUT ST U
RUPPOR D UKRA THAT S WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN REPUBLICAN
NGR WE ON
>>Y REMARKABLE
WHR PLAYER
RU TPOY,BALANCAGAINSA WHICH WHY
N DACY IN UAI'RE ON
>> DOES E RN
REAGAN'SHE
PUTIN, JTTONSTP TO
WHEREVER HE I GUESS ISIEW OFOUTS
E OF TD
WHAT SEEMS TO BE HAPNG
INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY RIG.
>> WELSH
YB LISTENING TO
LIUCKER CARLSON, BUT E'S A T
DOESN'T MEANE'
AT SOME OF HIS COLLEAGUESALL UBD
OFCIO SEEM ACIN, WHO IS
HAS HIS POLITICAL ENEMIES
RTABLE DEALINGOT SOBO T
REAO GORBACHEV USE HE SAW SOME
PEG
IN F AT LAND
COLLAPSEN'T THINK THESE PEOPLE
REALLY HAVE A
POLICY SENSE AT ALL, ANDA REALR
NOW, AND THERE A A G
RAITORISM, BUT TWORDS L
>> NO TIUTTHERE WAS THISE
RIGHT WH PD O PL
EMAN
HE WAS, YOU KNOW, VYING FOR THE
ESND WN  TIAL.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I'M ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT
OF THE FIRREME CNC MY ADMINIST
WILL BY
IF.GH DEMAND FOR ALL T
MAD INT, A TROBL SAYIN TWHEN YOR
IN 1981.
YOU KNOW, THERE HAVE BEEN 115
UR
AMERIC H8 M
IT WASN'T UNTIONRUNN M FOASIAN
AN
THUR 1FORE WE GOT ON THE
BUT, YOU KNOW, OF
COURSE PRESIDENTEN WAN TACK WOM.
THAT'S FINE.AND HI
OF TNGND H POINTED
TO THE FACATBUILONTO WIN IN 1980
AS
F S E
THAT THE UES
HISTOR
TEACHINGALCHOOLS.>> UNTILNLA FET
TE FACDRK
AL TOONY BLACK AMENSE
EITHER.
UPHEM ALL ACROSSE KIT OY  ARE TB
OUR COUNTRY ORO H
R TS WELL, YOU KNOW,Y FAERCOD I
SUPPOS FORG WHAT
E IT ME WHITE PELEE.
THATEAGALAW NOW, IN BY, OH, SA
AT IS THE TRUTH OFRI
AND IF RONeSD OTHEEPUBLICAN PAN
D.
BOS,AND TEACH R LITTLE
THE TRH NEEDOKHE
DID HIS BEST T